hey what's up guys it's rob you know
those little helicopter toys that you
can kind of twist in your hand and they
spin and fly down well i decided to try
to make one of those out of paper
i called jeremy shafer to see if he
wanted to design one too and he
definitely wanted to give it a shot we
folded
and tried a whole bunch of different
models for the paper helicopter spinners
well it took a little time to design one
that flew well we wound up creating two
or our very own designs for helicopter
spinners the cool thing about mine is
that not only can you throw it like a
dart like this and play catch with it if
you want but with a little
adjustment of the propellers once you
give it a spin it'll gently float down
to the ground
it's quick easy and a lot of fun for
everyone it's the propeller spinner
for the tutorial i'm going to be using a
white sheet of printer paper but you can
also use
a colored sheet or even origami paper
some of the folding gets a little thick
during certain parts so i wouldn't
recommend using cover or construction
paper
once you have the paper we can get
started
take the upper right corner and fold it
to the left side so that the top edge is
aligned and then you could remove the
excess paper by either tearing it
or cutting it with scissors now your
paper should have
a diagonal fold in it going from the top
left to the bottom right
[Music]
now that we have a diagonal crease going
this way we're going to take the upper
left corner and fold it down to the
bottom right corner
make a sharp crease and when you open it
you'll see an x in the paper
take the top and fold it down to the
bottom and once again align it and make
a nice sharp crease
open it back up twist it 90 degrees and
then fold the opposite edge
onto the bottom and once again crease it
when you open it up you'll see we now
have an
x and a plus in the paper now we can
take the top and bottom edges and fold
it directly onto the horizontal middle
line
crease it well and then do the same for
the bottom edge
once you open it you'll then see four
new horizontal sections in the paper
turn it 90 degrees and do the same with
the other top edge
and the bottom edge by folding them into
the center horizontal line
when we've finish the precreases we'll
have 16 squares in the paper
along with the plus and the x and we can
move on
[Music]
we're now going to turn the paper into a
modified pinwheel base that looks just
like this
to do that we can just re-crease the
paper on the diagonals like that
and then we're going to pinch the
corners
on the bottom here and push inwards
on the left and right edges with our
finger like this
as you can see the flaps are kind of
sticking up just flatten them down
like this and press it down so that the
paper looks like an upside down t
now we could flip it around and do the
same on this side
pinch the corners together so that the
edges come together and press them
inwards flattening out the entire paper
in the process
and it should look like this now we
could flip it over
and just make sure it's nice and flat
take the bottom and fold it to the top
sort of like a hot dog
and press down to ensure it's creased
sharply you'll notice there's two flaps
on the right or points and two on the
left
in between there's a v-shaped fold we're
going to take our finger and
press on that fold so that it rests
against the center of the paper
so we can just flip that fold by
pressing in the center here
and closing the two flaps on it flatten
the right side out
and then we can repeat it on the left
side open the two flaps and press
upwards on the bottom of the v in the
center so that the valley fold gets
tucked into the middle
you may need to press in the middle of
the v here to reverse the fold
and then once again close the two left
flaps
and flatten the paper out by pressing on
it when you've completed all the folds
the model should look just like this
i've drawn a vertical line where you
should see a crease in the middle of
your paper on both sides
you'll also see that there are two
foldable layers on the right and
two on the left take the top edge here
on the right top layer and fold it
directly next to the vertical line
leaving a small amount of space
once it's lined up just crease it on the
new fold and it will look like this
now we could take that new crease on the
right top edge and fold it to the middle
again
so just hold the center in place with
your left hand here
round the outside edge inwards a bit so
we could fold it into the center line as
well
so just round it and line it up with the
center it gets a little thick
but once it's lined up just crease it
all the way down
and make sure it's nice and flat once
you're finished it should look like this
now we're going to take the top left
edge and flip it over to the right
side flatten it out and do the same
exact thing
take the top edge here fold it next to
the center
line leaving a little bit of space once
again take the outside crease edge
round it into the middle and give it a
firm press and crease
trying to flatten it out so it lies on
top of the other one
the front of the paper should look like
this now
now we can flip it over and do the same
thing the top right edge into the middle
and then the outside edge into the
middle take the last
left flap flip it to the right side and
once again
fold the top edge into the middle and
then fold the outside into the middle
and flatten it out really well
now the paper should look like this and
this is the dark configuration and it
should look like an
arrow you can try throwing it like this
but now we can move on
[Music]
now that we have a model that looks like
this you can see i've drawn
a line at the base of the propeller
where you should notice an edge that
wraps around it here
we're going to grab one propeller with
our right thumb and pointer
and the opposite one with our left hand
and press gently in the middle so we
form
a cross or plus at this point
we're going to fold the propeller
downwards away from us
along that line that i've drawn so that
it lies
flat so just pinch it down just like
this
so that it looks something like that
then all we need to do is just
turn it and do the same thing with the
next one fold it back away from you and
give it a pinch at that crease
and finally the last two fold it back
and pinch it turn it
fold it back and pinch it so it looks
like a little ninja star
and we're ready to give it a test throw
okay so at this point i'm just going to
take it here and i'm just going to throw
it and i know it's probably not going to
spin
because we have to adjust it a little
bit but what i'm going to do is just
hold it like this and just
toss it out sort of like a dart
well it actually spun a little bit i'm
going to flatten it
i'm going to take these two edges and
squeeze them together like this
and take these two right edges and
squeeze them together
and just push it here just very gently
and then kind of push in the middle
and then try it again
there you go so now it's spinning a lot
more so you don't want these folded very
hard
but you're going to do that initially at
this little
crease right here fold it down but then
we're going to flatten it out a little
push gently hold it here like this and
just toss it out
it should also automatically spin if you
drop it so let's do the drop test
thanks for watching my tutorial for the
paper helicopter spinner i hope you guys
enjoyed it and that you were able to get
it to spin be sure to adjust it and to
make sure that the propellers are flat
and
facing up slightly like that not folded
too far down otherwise it won't spin
properly if you did enjoy the video be
sure to give it a thumbs up down below
and also be sure to subscribe and click
that notification bell if you haven't
already thank you guys so much for the
comments and support in the last video i
read i think
almost every comment and they were all
awesome so i really appreciate it and i
got some new content headed your way so
be sure to click that notification bell
and i'll see you soon